so I have a throw that question for you  now because I just got into an argument  about this with someone it's a Mean  Girls question and it's do you think  that Karen ever actually wrote anything  in the burn book  cuz I'm of the mind that she didn't know  no she did she totally didn't she was a  part of it but she didn't  it's just nothing to say about anything  anybody that's but she's nothing mean to  say about anybody  she's just associated with people who  are very insecure and you know I don't  think if she was just without the  plastics I don't think she would I don't  I don't think she would be a insecure  I mean her nail suck but like that's all  she didn't say about herself I'm pretty  sure that's the right answer now I just  won this argument thanks to you yeah